hi my name is marc jacobs and this is my
glamifesto for life
[Music]
my instant mood booster is to walk
outside to the garden
and just take a deep breath in the
sunshine how do i manage my mental
health
well first thing this morning after
getting showered and dressed which is
which is a huge part of my mental health
is self-care
um so so getting dressed and putting my
earrings on my pearl necklace uh doing
my hair everything
my eyebrows i feel like i've taken care
of myself i say my prayers in the
morning this is all part of self-care
and then i'm ready to start my day all
throughout
these months i kept thinking what if
what have we learned from this
experience and more specifically what
have i learned from this experience and
i think i'm in
the process now of understanding what
i've learned because i don't have a
clear answer i like zoom meetings and i
like zoom conversations
and i and i'll tell you the reason why
is because i get to do them from my
office with my dogs at my feet
and and i like being at home and looking
outside and seeing the garden you know
so i don't want to always be in an
office perfect
and i have a tattooed on my wrist as a
reminder that i'm i'm perfect as i am
and more in in greater detail i'm a
perfect being in a perfect world where
everything that happens benefits me
completely which is from the iching and
um and i i i think this is again in in a
very deep way you know it's about uh
acknowledging appreciating accepting
recognizing and and then also the
takeaway which is like what have i
learned from this experience whether
it's an experience that i like or an
experience i don't like there's
something to gain from the experience
fragrance is part of my i mean it's part
of my daily ritual i mean
scent is a huge i mean scent is
so
romantic and so beautiful and is so rife
with memories and
triggers and things like that so i have
i've always been a perfume person i mean
i've always worn a fragrance i think
creativity or creating things is my
passion
so um i mean i can feel passionate about
many things uh i can feel passionate
about art that someone has made that
that moves me or a movie that someone
has made that moves me but what what i
truly am
passionate about is what i get to create
with others you know because it's i'm
i'm part of a team a creative team
but i really love making things i could
not live without my husband and my dogs
not well i know i i don't live i mean i
live with failure some i think failure
is again a very tricky question because
i put very
i have very high expectations of me my
team and what we put out in the world
and
you know
we're i'm i'm the type of person who no
matter how good things are or how well
received they are there's always
something wrong there's always a mistake
it's never perfect i don't i wouldn't
say there's not a who
and they're many who's and many what's
are my or my great inspiration
i think you know
i i've always loved fashion and
i think my great inspiration comes from
the work of of brilliant designers
who've come before me or who are
contemporaries and and i think it's it's
clothing that has inspired me most oh
the quirkiest thing i do in the name of
wellness is post outfits on instagram
it's partially the post and it's
partially
the um
the reaction to the post but i have to
be in a really good mood
to dress up
and want to record it and want to share
it so it's a symbol of where i'm at
in terms of wellness if i'm that well
that i've posted a i mean if i record an
image of myself then you know i'm in a
good place i never think about my legacy
um
it's a weird thing i mean i think of
i think of
what's important i think what is
important is what is now like you know
legacy to me sounds like well when
you're gone what would you like to have
left behind
and honestly i'm just concerned with
what i'm doing not what i'm leaving
behind you know and and whether i'm
remembered or whether anything we've
created matters or whether it influences
or inspires
you know i i really it isn't what i
think about at all